[Music]
this is me driving in what I think is
one of the most bizarre places in the
world I just crossed over from Israel
into the West Bank if you look at a map
of where I'm driving right now you'll
see a jumbled mess of Palestinian towns
and villages which are shown in green
and Israeli settlements which are in
blue many people think of this territory
as Palestine but of the 3 million people
living out here almost 20 percent of
them are Jewish Israeli citizens the
Israelis living out here are called
settlers that live in the West Bank but
they're citizens of Israel as I Drive
I'm looking at effectively 2 different
nations woven into each other through
decades of conflict I visited 15
settlements all over the West Bank
talking to people who've decided to pack
up and move out into the middle of
disputed land will meet them in coming
videos but first I want to take a look
at the maps that help explain how the
West Bank got to look like this
[Music]
so let's go back to 1948 when the map
looked a lot different back then all
this land was controlled by Great
Britain and due to growing tensions
between Jews and Arabs the UN worked
with Britain to split the land into two
states one for Jews Israel and another
one for Arabs Palestine the Jews in the
region accepted this plan and declared
independence of the State of Israel but
the Arab states in the region saw this
plan is just more European colonialism
that didn't accept the plan and instead
declared war on Israel Israel won the
war pushing well past the borders of the
UN plan during the peace negotiations a
ceasefire line was drawn in green ink it
became known as the Green Line it wasn't
necessarily a border it was just a
ceasefire line with this being the State
of Israel and this section being
controlled by Jordan who had taken
control of it during the war the
Jordanians named this newly seized land
the West Bank because it was west of the
Jordan River the fragile ceasefire
remained until 1967 when Israel fought
another war with its Arab neighbors is
rayul wasn't looking to take over land
in this war but in just six days of
fighting it blew past the Green Line and
seized a whole swath of land including
the entire West Bank suddenly Israel had
a decision to make do they make the West
Bank a part of Israel and give the 1.1
million Arabs living there Israeli
citizenship and voting rights do they
give the land back to their enemy Jordan
or else do they let the people create
their own Palestinian state this became
a major debate in Israeli politics many
Israelis saw this war they just won as
not just a military victory but a
religious sign that the Jews were meant
to return to the place where a huge
amount of jewish history happened the
hills of the ancient Judea and Samaria
which is basically the entire West Bank
so while the government was debating
what to do
Israeli civilians began moving into the
West Bank without any permission from
the government they just started setting
up homes establishing a Jewish presence
in this region suddenly any debate about
what to do with the West Bank had to
take into account the growing number of
Israeli civilians that were living there
the rest of the world did not approve of
this as I said the presence grew the UN
issued a resolution saying that the
settlements had no legal validity and
that they constitute a serious
obstruction to achieving a comprehensive
just and lasting peace in the Middle
East they were basically saying that the
settler activity was totally illegal two
different narratives emerged here one
said that Jewish civilians were moving
on to mostly empty plots of land that
they had captured in a war and that had
deep historical and spiritual
significance to them the other side
which is the side that most of the world
took said that these settlers were
colonizing land to expand their nation
in spite of international condemnation
the number of settlers in the West Bank
grew over the next few decades more and
more factions of the Israeli government
began to support the settler movement
allocating public resources and granting
permits for building the Israeli housing
ministry and military began developing
plans on how to develop the West Bank
they built roads throughout the entire
region allowing easy access between
settlements in mainland Israel more and
more building permits were given out and
planned communities began popping up all
over the West Bank the settlements
slowly shifted from a fringe group of
motivated civilians to an
institutionalized part of Israeli
society totally supported by the state
here are the Palestinian towns in the
West Bank watch how the settlements
weave throughout these Palestinian towns
Palestinians didn't like this
encroachment they began protesting often
with extreme violence between the
violence and the condemnation from the
international community of the
settlements the situation became
unsustainable so in the mid-1990s
American President Bill Clinton Israeli
Prime Minister Yitzhak Rabin and
Palestinian leader Yasser Arafat signed
the Oslo Accords agreements that
established a Palestinian government and
split the West Bank into three sections
area a gave Palestinians total control
over security and government this makes
up about 18% of the West Bank but most
of the Palestinian population centers
are here this was a big deal because it
gave Palestinians self-rule for the
first time area B was designated for
Palestinian government control while
retaining Israeli security control
meaning the Israeli military remains
very present there area B is about 22
percent of the West Bank area C remained
completely under the Israeli military
and government control this is where all
the settlements are in Area C it's about
60 percent of the West Bank so this is
basically how we ended up with this mess
of a map Israelis can come and go from
mainland Israel through really nice
roads that go straight to the
settlements they call these roads
flyovers because they bypass Palestinian
villages and give easy access from one
settlement to the other but not every
settlement has one of these flyover
roads
Palestinians can drive on almost all the
roads in the West Bank but their
movement is often more difficult more
restricted they have to stop at
checkpoints and get the car inspected
sometimes sometimes it makes for some
really long lines but certainly one of
the most difficult aspects of this
carved up land situation is how it
hinders Palestinians from being able to
build an economy Area C which is under
Israeli control contains the majority of
the West Bank agricultural land as well
as the water and mineral resources
Palestinian companies are severely
restricted in accessing these resources
which takes a huge hit on their economy
so with these three sections agreed upon
by both sides the settlements continued
to grow in Area C but in 2005 something
happened that would ignite even more
passion for the settler movement in
Israel Prime Minister Ariel Sharon
decided to remove
8,500 settlers from the Gaza Strip which
was another disputed area where there
was a lot of settlements seen Israelis
forcibly evicted their homes demolished
left a huge mark on the country
especially the settlers they immediately
redoubled their effort to settle a West
Bank and the numbers continue to grow
most people who think about a resolution
to this conflict propose a two-state
solution meaning giving the Palestinians
estate somewhere in this West Bank
region but if you look at this map you
can start to see that it's getting
harder and harder to do that the
settlers living in the West Bank are not
living in tents or caravans they're
living in developed communities with
schools and hospitals and even a
university it's not going to be that
easy to uproot these communities in the
next video I'll go inside the
settlements and talk to the people who
are living there Jewish people come home
that's that's not going to change who
are these nutcases who are moving out of
their own will into this battle zone
they fail to realize the lifestyle that
we actually have here I don't consider
myself a settler maybe but I know other
people do just because I cross a certain
line and I go through a certain post